العلاقات التجاريه والدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه
التركيه قد تتاثر بشكل كبير في حال فوز
احد الطرفين كيف تبدو فرص عقد شركات
اقتصاديه مهمه الى جانب الغاء التاشيرات
للمواطنين الاتراك تبدو اقوى في حال
فوزكار اوغلو فالاخير قد يستجيب بشكل اكبر
لشروط الاتحاد الاوروبي من قبل بل من قبل
اطلاق سراح السجناء السياسيين والالتزام
باستقلاليه القضاء وهي شروط لم يبدع
اردوغان
استعدادا كبيرا للاستجابه اليها كما ان
فوز كيتشدار اوغلو من شانه ان يفتح المجال
امام الاستثمارات الاوروبيه عكس اردوغان
الذي يبدو اكثر تحفظا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات